you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on HS org and
I'm gonna do a group of three puzzles
and just share my thoughts along the way
so we'll do one from each of these three
categories here and in this first one
white to move so let's see this rating
by the way is uh up until this point
pretty much a team rating I've only
really done puzzles while on stream and
it's been a collaborative effort to get
to that rating so let's see if we could
only improve upon it hmm okay I've seen
this tactical motif before so I know the
solution to this one so forced me in
three so take this bishop first maybe
before I move draw some arrows here
takes King takes just to help a little
bit with the visual calculation Queen
takes bishop King takes Knight f5 is
double check and there's only one reply
that King has to go back to g8 and then
Knight to h6 is me so I found that the
easy puzzles tend to be forced mates but
not all the time this case I'm eight and
three that's a good one
I'll give it an arrow up and just
quickly see where this was pulled from
these puzzles are pulled from games that
have been played on the site and let's
see how we got to that position and
let's see if white actually came up with
the solution just kind of skipping
through real quick did white end up
getting it they did very cool okay let's
check out puzzle - let's check out a
normal puzzle
okay yet another one white to move here
well the first thing I'm thinking about
with this one is that the queen is a
little bit misplaced and I'm trying to
find a way to trap the Queen hmm I
believe we can do that hmm as it stands
right now the Queen has many options for
options as a start I'm seeing a way that
where white can make one move and mmm
restrict the Queen you know she can't
move to three of those if we play Knight
h4
these three are taken away in fact these
four are taking away the knight is
controlling g2 so I'll move like Knight
h4 and then Bishop to g4 would trap the
Queen but of course White has a move in
well excuse me Black has a move that
they could be making so let's see Knight
h4 there's moves like f5 stopping Bishop
g4 or even h5 this side this move right
here I'd categorize under a quiet move
so let me look for something a bit more
forceful one that throws a punch of the
Queen a bit more directive hmm and
there's Knight g5 but what are we doing
after Queen h6 I don't see how to get to
the Queen from that position what's the
material count
okay black is up upon but he'll be won
back but the trickier should probably be
to hunt down this Queen I think on
Knight g5 Queen h6
I really don't see what the follow-up is
we no longer have that dark square
Bishop around that would conveniently
control h6 so
9 th for problem yeah it must be night H
for night h4 and suppose one of these
two because otherwise it's Bishop f1 and
the queen is gone or bishops Bishop here
okay so night each for suppose one of
these two controlling g5g for then hmm
then if Bishop f1 right away the Queen
could pivot on g4 in this case the pawn
would be controlling the g4 square but
maybe there's a quiet move this might be
a quiet move to start and then a quiet
move for the second turn for white so in
other words Knight h4 let's let's run
with I really can't wrap my head around
the difference between f5 and h5 let's
just say f5 is played night h4 f 5
instead of Bishop f1 maybe we first take
away the g4 square with f3 and only then
on our next move will we play Bishop to
f1 and the Queen will be gone there is
this check that could be thrown in but
it could always be met with c3 pawn
takes pawn takes were you throwing
another punch at black they could return
to F or excuse me c5 I have pressure
here but any sacrifices on f2 we're just
recapturing and it still remains well
still the same story the queen is in
some hot water here she will be trapped
I believe that's it let's give it a shot
it is correct
okay it's opting for h5 controlling g4
and I believe one more quiet move f3 and
then we're gonna get the Queen yes that
is correct and okay so I guess this is
the best that black can do I should have
won and I don't think it really matters
king takes Queen takes I don't see a
difference I guess rook takes oh you
could still queenside castle I think
either one would be good okay I got that
one I think that's a pretty good one
let's see where it was pulled from have
a quick look did white end up getting it
could see the stats when the game was
played who the players were top left
they're just zipping through here no
they just went looked at the recapturing
on d4 okay so they didn't come up with
that tactic and this one but let's move
on let's check out this last puzzle
under the hard group and let's see if we
could get this one hmm my first thought
is that maybe this puzzle doesn't belong
under the hard group hmm I have been
mistaken before with these though
sometimes they look maybe not so hard
but they're a little bit too involved
here some deep calculation hmm well we
only have two pieces to really work with
here playing playing his white bishop
and queen hmm might be tough to control
this b6 square
multiple checks here here here hmm
I'm not sure where my mind should be
focused on this one I mean I'm looking
at the checking moves but I'm also
wondering how do I get another piece
involved in the attack I believe we need
that like I don't know a pawn move to
get the bishop out to hit here or Knight
c3 coming into a four to control this I
don't see how are the Queen er the Queen
I was already sad let's see how the
bishop can control b6 if anyone else
knows how that could be a possibility
let me know so it's it's difficult to
get the Queen even controlling this
square
I mean moves like this check King here
that's mate right away but after
checking here
what's the follow-up then Oh actually I
am seeing it we don't we don't need any
other pieces besides the Queen and
Bishop I think this is the correct start
Queen check King here is forced
otherwise King b6 Queen and b5 mate
so Queen check King here and then the
Queen can make use of f5 check and if
the King goes back home
Bishop f7 is mate and if he goes to c6
when the queen is on f5 Queen B 5 is
another mate and so check King here
check we're down to this one being the
last option for what for black in which
case we can do what
probably just come back over to d5 first
take the pond King here come back here
with check same story King v6 Queen b5
mate and if the King comes back over
here we once again revisit f5 with check
and this time there's no longer a pond
on e7 so there's no e six move and so
what are the options for black then if
he goes back home it's not Bishop f7 but
rather Queen f7 if he goes here it's
Queen e6 me and if he goes back here
it's made over here okay so this is
another forced mate I don't know what is
that five or six moves deep I believe
this is the correct start though that is
correct
clean f5 that's correct
take with the Queen and then return here
so far so good
once again revisit f5 keeping an eye on
this Square and its mate next Queen B 5
may again if you went here we actually
had two different actually not two
different ones here or here it would be
Queen f7 mate in here on c6 that right
there is the mate I have experienced
more difficult ones from the hard group
on leach s but this was yet another
forced made sequence that's a pretty
good one and I just has a close let's
see yet again where this puzzle was
pulled from take it right from the top
here okay
lights coming right out for the scholars
me and did they pull this one off now
well they didn't maybe they revisits no
they're not going in that direction are
they I think it was still possible after
takes here
oh no it's saying that they lost the
force checkmate sequence but after king
d7 now it's back on check and that's not
the direction to go and so they didn't
end up getting that forced mate sequence
that's the remainder of it but anyhow
interesting a group of three feel free
as usual to leave any comments in the
comment section below to this video and
feel free to share how you did with
these three puzzles yourself in the
comment section below so that's all for
now as usual I hope you got something
out of it
take care
you